tell people about the average American
average American is obese Divorced with
less than 1K in the bank so by doing
what everyone else does it seems like a
safe route it's actually a reliable way
to achieve a life that you don't want
exactly yeah so many people are are
fighting to do the normal thing the
normal thing is to play it safe the
majority of people are pessimists
because the majority of optimist people
found their way out of the gene pool
there's going to be some absolute
experts in human evolution that going
like but ultimately any single human
through hundreds of thousands of years
oh yeah we'll get across that River out
the
oh it's not that cold out out the je the
evolution is all of the people that are
risk adversed worried about things going
wrong and avoiding all the opportunities
that are around them to the point that
they don't take risks but now we have
this massive Primal mechanism of fear
that is supposed to Keep Us Alive and
now we're associating that mechanism of
fear to really trivial stuff like how
does my CV look what if I ask the girl
for a number and she says no we're using
this massive primitive Keep Us Alive
mechanism to everyday tasks and it's
keeping people from doing the one like
in the past only the paranoid survived